si elle définitivement sans nuages une
chaleur étouffante ce sont les plus
fragiles qui sont les premiers touchés
il y avait du monde deux urgences tour
d'horizon matelly moisan année tri boire
les pelouse et le bassin ont beau être
interdit
en ce jour de canicule les jets d'eau
attire irrésistiblement les parisiens et
tant pis si l'eau n'est pas très
transparents ou habitués
en plus à du monde du pari quoi au samu
pas plus d'appels que d'ordinaire les
médecins prodigue toujours la même
recommandation forcer les jeunes enfants
et les personnes âgées à s'hydrater
le conseil c'est de boire de l'ordre
d'un litre et demi par jour pour un
adulte il faudrait rajouter autant de
lors des grandes chaleurs
donc si on compte bien ça fait 3 litres
3 litres ces deux mecs six bouteilles
dans cette maison de retraite de gaillac
dans le tarn la température atteint 30
degrés dans les chambres les
pensionnaires se partagent quelques
précieux ventilateur
le personnel doit aspergé les plus
fatigués pour les personnes en fin de
vie ça peut leur être fatal d'être
confronté à une très très grosse chaleur
la sécheresse affecte aussi les récoltes
surtout dans l'est de la france
les rangs de blé sont clairsemés et les
épis peut développer le nombre de grains
sur la longueur des piles est très
faible
ceux ci ont même rétréci du fait de la
chaleur actuelle et on se retrouve avec
des parcelles très très clair dans le
sud du lot
il est à présent interdit de pomper
l'eau des rivières les agriculteurs
doivent se contenter comme ici des
bassins qui collecte les eaux de pluie
les producteurs de melon du quercy
redoutent que cela n'affecte la qualité
de leurs produits